log date 7 1 5 2 we have come across the
last episode of Steven universe that
we'll be doing for a while I have to say
for the last episode we'll be seen for a
while welke really say about this
episode the episode when I can see for a
while frankly captain you're being
ridiculous I mean it as a kid I'm saying
it's good but yeah this a peg hey
peridot want a fuse here in the bar my
parents said only until we're married
it's okay put on some relaxing music mom
we dance first so we're like they
talking about that it really does like
this episode really like to be felt like
there is something sexual about it just
like you always felt like a little bit I
know it's always been there is like kind
of a subtext but like you're it's like
but now for the first time I'm like
putting the music out is something I'm
like I'm the asshole like snickering in
the corner garden hey it's ears I think
that's something I really do like about
though is that's not hey Fusion is sex
and that's it I didn't like the bit a
lot of various things I suppose the name
of it shows something pines yeah look
the guy was that supposed to be I think
they're awesome like Dawson's Creek with
like Canada like you know like done
maybe dogs like in the early WB network
kind of show maybe yeah would like this
Canadian kind of like with most of the
stuff on both Steven universe and other
shows like gravity falls and stuff you
can usually catch what combination of
shows that is about watching a like this
is a Cuttino I do it's pretty Canadian
camping at it but bow and Jesus is like
oh it's like those two and she's like oh
now I get it
um I will say cuz you know you get these
titles like you know it could have been
great message received and then log days
is seven five one two and I'm thinking
like this is gonna be a date that will
live in infamy like the big big battles
like oh it's just like gems are gonna
freakin Pearl Harbor the plan
with pearl with pearls oh yeah like I
like oh that was a door yeah it was good
um I you know it's funny we were talking
I feel like this would Ned this is that
this a bad episode I just feel like this
would have been fine before the finale
yeah but who the hell knows how they're
releasing this cuz Amazon maybe there's
some super finale we have it why I've
been walking off the Wikipedia one oh
yeah it was cute it was a shoot I it was
it was push the door um what else say I
think there's uh you know we were
talking about in the episode before it's
like you know when do you let someone
you know go when you LEM take so much of
you and stuff like that I think this
episode is kind of the opposite where
you see kind of this patience with
garnet who even when you know it seems
almost very motherly you know every
single time paradox yawn at her saying
something being you know she's they're
trying to be encouraging giving a thumbs
up you know few words of letting herb so
work out through her stuff and her just
giving the little hints and the little
you know just drawing a path but she has
to take it um so I like that I like I
feel like we haven't seen maybe cuz when
peridot came in it just suddenly became
I'm not against it but it kind of became
the pair of that show for a while we're
peridot at Steven show so maybe how
daredevil season two is really Punisher
Season one that's what I haven't seen it
yet but that's why here everybody say
pretty much how you have seen it yet I
busy sorry how do you not see that yeah
um I am only on Episode six yes a shop
but it still acts aren't there like only
nine episodes or something
no yeah only episode six
um but yeah it's one of those things
where it's nice to kind of see garnet
you know like it's a garnet and peridot
episode um
and yeah it's kind of nice to see that I
like the little I like the joke when he
fast for is he just see her going
through the motions and the store that
fast animation thunks yeah darn it's
like
I yeah I can't yeah
I mean it's always nice to see something
sign it's a fine episode it's fine
everything's fine how are you so shy it
it's nice what I artisan say about it it
just was boy
uh no it was good I thought it was uh
definitely I had some good laughs in a
it wasn't not that we learned I'm
curious if we can do something with that
connection between them cuz it's kind of
like I mean your head I guess with often
they make a little bit of a connection
and maybe with garnet there's already
like a lot of distance because she was
like yeah she said but she's insulted
all them pearl was a you know lower
being and amethyst you know she tried to
manipulate as well and it's kind of like
it what garnet it's like those I guess
that was the two of them coming together
now um you know which is nice to see
it's nice to see it dumped through like
you know the the past though you're kind
of right why wasn't this an episode so
we're in this is the timeline because is
the very ending of this episode after
the previous episode it has because
she's saying I betrayed yellow diamond
haha
oh my god hi you know going back and
forth the whole time that's right and
then soon fixes sorry ed there were it
was a good episode but they jump around
a lot jumping around so much within the
tape recording I forgot where we started
okay
you know the one thing I realize are
maybe not but with garnet being a fusion
um you know I get her size cuz that's
two very tiny people fusing together so
she would be about that size cuz all the
others are much bigger and stuff but
should she have like three arms or four
legs or something like don't slim shamed
untrue the originals only have like what
army will shaming that a thing I would
be shocked it comes if there is
something out there tumbler will make it
a thing yeah tell metell was just
watching right now just even you ever
have corn so they're watching just like
lima sure because that's something I can
angry about it I'm just not a huge fan
of asparagus asparagus shaming um so
yeah can't forget too much else I know I
feel bad this is gonna be but I'm like I
can't whatever I said whatever she's
been a great righteousness and that was
the end
no more episode bye it's over that's all
right yeah there's no more that's a
weird one to go out on all right that
they were just there but we hope you
enjoyed it too we hope you enjoyed life
well some of you in one nice thing uh
the color in this one particular would
be out true no I did but the color on
this potatoey with peridot uh I write
every once while like they do something
with the green on her cuz you ever
notice I like sometimes it's like oh
just sort of a normal green other times
it's like neon punch you in the eye
green it's like super super green uh
depending on her emotional state um baby
or the lighting or whatever and when
they get angry Reena is really mean sexy
baby um but uh yes so in terms of future
Vee logs out like I said we'll do we'll
do some more we'll keep doing steam
universe as they come out I don't know
the timeframe yeah because we this will
be the first time we're watching them as
they're coming out so I mean and
according to these Stephen bombs I mean
you know it might be a couple or a while
slow and fast I don't know so um yeah
and in terms of a new V log series to
get out everyday um like I said I don't
I don't know which one we're gonna do
yet but we have about three or four that
we're figuring out right now Oh cut it
out Nikki um so yeah that's about it and
we'll see you either the next Steven
universe be wog or the next movie like
we'll see you then take care
we hope you enjoyed the neon green it's
been